hello everyone and welcome to another
very interesting game and by very
interesting it could very well mean the
best game played so far as it's a really
an interesting game from the round five
of the Batumi chess Olympia 2018 the
matches Armenia vs. Azerbaijan 11 aragon
versus a clear mommy dr of on board one
and it's really a game really an
impressive showing by both of them and
it really shows you that even though in
today's modern age of engines still it's
possible to create something over the
board so without further ado let's check
out this very nice game ireland has the
white pieces and he opens with E 4 we
have e5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop to b5 Duru Lopez a6 morph is
defense Bishop to a4 Knight to f6
we have castles in the night captures on
e4 a well known line but we have d4
Bishop to e7 and now rook to e1
attacking the knight on e4 mummy Dara
replies would be 5 this is the strongest
response and now comes Luke captures on
e4 and now you don't capture immediately
here because if we capture immediately
white can push d5 dislodge your knight -
starting square and then recapture on e5
and the white would be much better here
so instead after rook captures only four
first you have time to play d5 now comes
again this is all still standard theory
Knight captures on e5 and here again you
don't want to capture the rook if you
capture the rook you get the Knight
captures on c6 with an attack on the
Queen Queen has to move that will matter
where captures captures and then you
will save the bishop and having a bishop
and a knife for a rook white is up too
much material well not too much for
white but black would be lost here after
95 we have Knight captures on e5 first
rook captures on e5 and only now B
captures on a4 and queen 21 so what do
we have here out of the opening it's
only move 11 we have the Queen and rook
battery I'm the e-file not allowing
black the castle as rook captures on e7
would be winning for white and you can
see that
medea of squint-eyed is somewhat
shattered but the plus side for Mama
Darrell is that he has the bishop repair
and if he's able to either castle or
perhaps artificially castle would have
16 to Kim to f7 then he could perhaps
create a very strong attack against the
white king as arrogance pieces are still
somewhat undeveloped so f6 displayed
here and here their disposition was
already on the board it's available in
the database database in 2014 it was
played in the Dutch league between Robin
van Campen and Arvin la me where rook to
e2 was played that game was drawn for
this game Aragon plays rook to e3 and
now we have a completely new game a game
that was never played before
c5 media of a very nice idea he strikes
where our engine is the weakest as he
still hasn't developed any of his pieces
now it's kind of hard to develop your
rook is kind of in the way of your
Bishop getting developed you can't go
Knight c3 because now captures wood we
knew the piece so you do have to do
something about this after some
consideration Ariane decides to leave
the e-file as king to f7 is definitely
coming there's no way to prevent this
so Queen to d1 now preparing Knight to
c3 as now the Queen is guarding the d4
pawn we have castles knights the c3 as
planned and then now rook to b8
pressuring the b-pawn be three we have
seek after Sundy for Queen captures on
d4 and now comes up to d6 you're gonna
lose the dis d5 point you could protect
it for example with Bishop here but then
Knight captures on a forest coming the
knight can come to c5 and you want your
bishops to be able to attack and the
bishop on b7 is pretty much in the way
of the rook and pretty much hitting its
own pawn so instead
mama D or F has a very original idea he
goes Bishop to d6 he puts this Bishop on
a very active diagonal and he gives up
the d5 pawn onion captures it and he
captures it with check nonetheless Queen
captures on d5 with check King to h8 and
now Queen to d3 not allowing any Bishop
captures on h2 ideas in the future okay
the knight is here for the moment but
you know that can change
we have Queen to e8 a very nice idea as
it was a very dangerous Aragon was
threatening to capture the bishop and
now such things would be impossible due
to Queen to e1 checkmate okay after
Quint we ate we have Bishop to b2 and
now comes the Bishop to e5 countering
White's Bishop on b2 Knight captures on
a for our onion offers a trade of
bishops and now comes Luke to b5 first
attacking our onions Queen and now you
have to decide what do you want to do
and where do you want to move the Queen
do you want to go to c4 do you want to
go all the way to a eight or perhaps
they want to go back to f3 as you pretty
much know that Mommy Dearest plan is to
go to b7 to pressure g2 and all also the
Queen might come to g6 the bishop is
covering g3 so you're not gonna be able
to confront the Queen with the rook so
our neon decides to bring back the Queen
to help out with the defense rush up to
b7 again a nice developing move with an
attack on the Queen Queen to e3 and here
comes the start of mommy our beautiful
creation here a lot of moves are
possible you can simply bring the Queen
into the attack you can exchange Bishop
supership capture some b2 but the move
Mammadov place is really really
something else
Bishop to e4 and okay perhaps this move
came as a surprise to Arden and perhaps
it didn't and I don't know there was
there was no interview with either of
them after the game but you have to
decide what to do here of course now you
can't capture as now your queen is
unguarded Bishop captures on h2 would
lose you to Queen but after Bishop to b4
you could move the rook which is what
Ireland played Rock the b2 and now comes
mama DRS a great idea Bishop captures on
g2 so what what is really the idea here
this is definitely perhaps even the
critical moment of the game because here
you really have to decide what to do
Ireland decided to capture the bishop
immediately King captures on g2 you'll
see what happens and then you'll realize
why I move like f4 was stronger
if you play f4 first before you decide
to capture the bishop yes this is
stronger as you threaten the bishop if
the bishop moves you will immediately be
able to exchange Queens but then you
have to figure out what happens after
Bishop to b7 and then you say okay I'll
win a piece back as not back but as I
didn't capture the light square Bishop
I'm gonna capture the dark square bishop
but then you see Queen to c6 and then
when you see this position from that
position where you're deciding whether
to capture on g2 or not you're gonna
decide to no I don't want to I don't
want to play this but then you find
Queen to f4 if you look deeper and then
you see that you perhaps will be able to
defend this attack Queen h1 check King
f2 and now after Queen g2 check King
moves a black is a black Sutekh runs out
of steam White's defended and now white
is the one actually winning here as he
is up simply too much material there's
no way for you to open the F file as the
rukon f8 is unguarded there's no way to
increase the pressure here Queen g1 will
be met with Queen to f1 and now after
Queen g5 you will get rook a to D 1 rook
to d8 is coming white will simply simply
trade the down and win this game but
seeing a move like f4 over the board not
not gonna happen
King captors on g2 was played and now
comes Queen to g6 this comes with Chuck
King to f1 and now comes Bishop captures
on h21 one more reason why perhaps you
know you could have explored this f4
possibility but okay I don't think
anyone who would be able to find this
over the board here rook to e1 was
played by Aragon and this wasn't the
greatest the greatest idea you do want
to prevent this rook from coming to g5
if this rook comes to g5 and then to g1
it will be very unpleasant for white but
instead of preventing it would remove
like 92 c5 also finding a move like this
over the board very very difficult after
rook to e8 attacking the Queen and now
you have to find Knights to e6 and okay
now it seems like you're guarding the g5
square now with the night but then you
get Queen to g1 check King - E - Queen
to g4 check f3 and now Queen captures on
six so you win the night but now comes
Queen captures rook captures and King to
f1 the bishop is under attack you move
the bishop and prevent checkmate and
after rook to d7 it's a pretty equal
position three points against the one on
the Queen side whereas black would have
three points against one on the Kings
side with this rook to d7 white gained
some activity but all in all it's a
pretty rush position perhaps aren't on
solids but he was still maybe even
exploring possibilities how to win this
game so instead of going for this
seemingly draw a line onion tries to go
and create something beautiful he
decides to play rook to e1 he allows
mama drf to attack his King and his idea
is also very nice rocked g5 as planned
by manager of the rook is coming to g1
now comes King to e2
and now you see what ironin had in mind
rook to e8 my maduro is now threatening
to capture the Queen and Erinn defends
this with King to be one he simply moves
the King and you cannot capture the
Queen should you capture the Queen
immediately you're gonna get a rook to
d8 check rogue blocks rogue capture
screen captures and after rook captures
this is checkmate on the other hand
after King to d1 you don't want to
capture immediately but first you play
rook to g1 first my media of pins are on
Young's rook now capturing the rook
doesn't really do anything because after
Queen captures you can't capture your
rookie spin you have to capture here and
then black has a bishop and a queen
against the Bishop Knight and the rook
black is up simply too much material in
the winning
so after this rook to g1 move on and
finds a beautiful defensive resource
he brought he definitely saw this when
he decided to go for this entire King to
e2 to d1 maneuver and that is Bishop to
Bishop to e5
you cannot capture the bishop with the
rook if you capture here then again rook
to d8 will lead the checkmate after
rogue d8 captures captures and captures
and now black is checkmated so after
Bishop to e5 Bishop captures on e5 okay
you do have to give back some material
and now rook to e2
tripling on the e-file h5 Mamedov
doesn't allow for any checkmate ideas
now at the h7 square is all available to
the black king and the now Queen to d3
Aragon simply offers a trade of Queens
mamita of course declines this Queen to
g2 and now comes 9th to be six iron and
is now ready to bring his knight back
into the game
rook captures anyone with Czech rook
captures and now Queen captures on f2
and as you can see blacks position is is
much better here and not just because
he's up a pawn but his bishop on e5 is a
very powerful piece and since white
doesn't have a dark square bishop he
does have a knight yes but there are far
too many dark square weaknesses in
White's camp and it will be really
difficult to come across this Knight to
d5 is played and with c4 Aragon will
also create a very nice outpost for his
knight on d5 but that's that is far less
important there is no way to protect
both the a to pawn and create this very
nice outpost so okay rook to d8 mama D
of pins the night it doesn't allow for
any tricks and now comes c4 yes the
outpost for the White Knight is created
but you have to give up the a to pawn
and now you will be down to pawns on the
other hand there really isn't a useful
move here for white for example rook to
f1 yes you could try and dislodge the
Queen but Queen to g2 still this comes
with a double attack against White's
night and you would have to push c4 here
and again black would simply capture an
A - so after Ruby d8 c4 is played
guarding the night and now Queen
captures on a - now being down two
points and with a with a superior
position there really is no way for
whites to do anything here if it was a
tournament game where every man would
play for himself
most likely Aaron would resign here but
nah it's a team event so you do have to
hope that perhaps your opponent will
make a mistake Queen to f3 was played
and now comes g6 defending the h5 pawn
rook to e3 and now King to g7 and
mommy-daughter improves the position of
the king and now Queen to h3
perhaps with some ideas of of
infiltrating blacks position
but mamedyarov will not be tricked he
plays Queen to f2 and I would have to be
really careful if you play something
like Queen to d6 then you you allow
ideas like Queen captures on e3 the
knight is pinned you can't capture back
and even if you capture the rook for
example Queen e7 King here Queen
captures there really isn't anything for
whites to do here Queen d3 check King
moves and now h4 you will either push
this point to victory even if white
checks you there's really mmm no
prospect here for white white is without
a move black can simply play anything
and win so rook the d3 getting the rook
out of Queens away and now comes Queen
g1 check King moves and now Queen to h2
with this move Momotaro Momotaro is
successful in exchange in Queens Queen
captures Bishop captures and now rook to
h3 attacking the bishop bishop moves
back and king to d3 okay white queen is
the white king is a bit more active but
still it's an endgame where white is
black is up two pawns there really is no
discussion here a5 preventing before we
have King to e4 and now King to f7
Mammadov also decides to improve the
position of his King King f3 now we have
worked to h8 mamita was preparing to
pull g5 King to g2 g5 is coming now the
h5 point is protected by the rook 92 III
King to e6 now we have King to f1 and
here after f5 it was in this position
that 11 iron and decided to resign the
game I think it's really a wonderful
game there's nothing to look for here
what's in black is up simply too much
material whatever why decides to play
black will simply push the pawns on the
King side and it will be an easy win for
example g4 rock moves h3 check King
moves now you have to move the King not
to allow any tricks but then g3 g2 is
coming the bishop is covering the dark
squares and it will all be over very
soon
so after a 5 iron and resigned the game
and wonderful and a very important
victory for shocker Mahmud Europe and
his team who are coming in to round 6
with a perfect score
and yeah we've already seen the results
here you have it so that's a photo of
Aragon with his a nice cat t-shirt which
I already mentioned it's really funny
because you know we all know how much he
loves his dog panchak which I believe
means donut in Russian but still not
sure about that so yeah I really hope
you enjoyed that I really enjoyed it
because it's really first it was a
really creative line to play then my
meteor goes for this very exciting
Bishop to e4 and then sacrifices the the
same Bishop on g2 and instead of going
for the droids line Ireland goes for
that very exciting King to e2 to d1
maneuver very very creative game and I
really enjoy when either players decides
to create something over the board so I
mean and it's also very interesting
pretty not so I mean as you all know
today is Ireland's first wedding
anniversary first year anniversary so I
don't feel all that great about showing
a game where he lost on his big day but
also my media of I became a father a few
days ago so you know kind of like a like
an even-steven I guess so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and I do
hope you are enjoying the coverage of
the Olympics so far I would like to
thank Brady Erindale Luis Felipe Buddha
the Oliviera Michael Buckley dan
O'Hanlon and John Tory for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - in my previous
video CR thank all for watching and I
will see you soon most likely continuing
the official series but you know every
day so many games in the limpid are
played and I feel I will have to cover
most of the interesting ones so and I
almost forgot
do check the first thing you'll see in
the description below is the the last
five minutes of this game it's a
recording from chess base India's
channel so do check it out very exciting
to see the last moments of this epic
match the game thank you all and I'll
see you soon